anyway we had a number of writers uh in
the book who said we won't write
anything now if we can't get director or
producer credit because we just don't
want people messing with our stuff then
Charlie Peters had that great quote he
said I'm just so tired of pitching two
embryos that's what I wanted to title
his chapter he also told a great story
about how much the business has changed
in about eight years ago he went to a
meeting he got a job and he went to a
meeting this is a guy who's written
everything and he went to a meeting and
as they were just gonna start talking
about the story they weren't anywhere
near even developing a script and the
producer said what do you think it's
gonna be like opening weekend he won you
know and Charlie said I don't know 60 65
and rainy you know the guy wouldn't talk
about the poster and they hadn't even
written the movie yet but you know it's
it's interesting when we when we
interviewed Sherwood Schwartz the way he
began his interview was saying when we
were in our day somebody would come in
and they they show me a script and I'd
say I just saw something like that on my
three sons a couple of weeks ago and I
throw them out he says now people won't
accept anything unless it's been done
somewhere else to show that it works he
says you know my day was creativity and
you had to be new and fresh so now
everybody wants to be safe that's that's
so true and it's it's interesting as a
slight change of genres but I I went to
a taping of a show some some friends of
friends had bought some rehearsal
studios in Burbank
and they were having big-name groups
come in do a rehearsal in front of a
live audience and then sit and take
questions from them and so we got to see
one with Manhattan Transfer who I love
and they were talking about the
difference in the business and saying
when we first started and record
companies you had a and our people who
are artists and so you had artists
helping artists get their product on he
says now it's all I can't
and he says when we present a project
the word they use is what kind of
tonnage I want to do and and they said
that word with as much of an air of
repugnance as you could do saying they
don't care what we put out if it's going
to sell a lot and certainly that's even
truer in in movies and TV is sort of a
sad commentary that you know there were
there were days you know when your dad
was around and before where producers
had a sense of art and they were looking
for good products and now it's
corporations who have again the a word
comes up them and it's sort of sad that
the bean counters should should
determine what's art and one of one of
the things that we're finding so
interesting is like the stuff that you
folks are doing because Jeffrey and I
gave a talk at a writers conference down
in San Diego and there was a fellow
there from a company named Smashwords
and what he does is he has a website for
people who want to do electronic book
publishing and he will help them with
formatting and give them templates and
stuff so they can get it
anybody can get out there and the point
he was saying was until a few years ago
there was a small group of editors and
publishers and literary agents who
determined what the world would read
they were the gatekeepers would your
book get published or wouldn't it he
says that's changed now
and now anybody can publish a book
electronically get it up on iTunes get
it up on Amazon they're out there the
same thing has happened with the music
industry you know there are no more
record stores that's a thing of the past
and you used to have to get a record
company to get behind you to afford
studio time to go in and make records
now you've $2,000 you can put out a
state of the art quality the stuff from
your own studio and what we're seeing
more and more now is people now you know
when you wanted to do a movie just to
rent the equipment and put it onto film
priced you out of the business but now
you can you can use avid you can use
Final Cut Pro Premiere and you can do
your own feature editing you can you can
do it on video you can distribute it all
the way down to people doing webisodes
and and having blogs and doing all the
stuff so that now you don't have to have
these big companies which means they're
sort of losing their stranglehold a bit
I mean the only thing that sort of keeps
the the movie industry going is the
distribution channels so it's it's all
changing very very quickly it's kind of
fun and it's it's the interesting thing
that technology is doing ya know I
funny story apropos of nothing I had a
friend years ago who taught in a music
department and she had a doc in piano
performance and just to make small talk
I asked her if she had seen this new
sequencing program music sequencing
software is basically you can take a
computer put in notes from a synthesizer
assign the sounds you want to them and I
could sit down and recreate a Beethoven
symphony on it and she looked at me very
huffily and said that's putting
musicians out of work and then later I
saw her going in to teach a class
wheeling at a phonograph and I thought
how funny that she doesn't realize his
story
we that that's the thing that killed
live music that there was a time you
know when people write music now the
idea they get a publishing deal with a
record company but publishing used to
mean literally publishing sheet music to
put on your piano and play because real
people who wanted music in their houses
how to play music till the phonograph
and she looks at this new technology and
doesn't realize this old technology was
there doing that so yes thank us again
it was it was movie theaters and then TV
and now computers and all these avenues
are opening up for young filmmakers
young writers young directors
cinematographers that's what you guys
are doing
it's basically your Pioneer wild
frontier I will say the one place where
they seem to fail at that and they
should have is when they tried a couple
of years ago to replace live music the
Broadway musicals because there's
nothing like sitting down and for what
they charge especially because there's
you know like um Book of Mormon was like
two hundred and twenty-five dollars a
ticket for a lousy seat you know and to
get there to pay all that money and then
they're gonna can't they're gonna bring
in can music so they luckily the unions
set up and so they made some kind of
deal where they have fewer musicians but
I still think there's nothing like live
music you know it's great it's great you
know so yeah you know in terms of
opportunities it's like you know you
said you started out doing radio stuff
you used to have to get on a radio
station and very limited number of slots
and you had to jump through hoops and
you had no control and yeah and now a
video same thing you used to have to be
able to get on a network
you